à un jour du début des concerts les
scènes se monte petit à petit la
pression monte plus de 20000 spectateurs
sont attendus pour les cafetiers des
alentours
la soirée de demain s'annonce donc
lucrative le nombre de tirs aux ondes
l'aphasie je pense qu'il y en aura au
moins elle aura minimum 3 voilà à la
coupe du monde on en avait
5 il me semble on a écoulé du monde 80
fut voilà donc on s'attend peut-être pas
en écouler autant au concert de rentrée
mais je pense qu'on va quand même gonflé
le chiffre pour faire face à l'affluence
les bars vont devoir s'organiser
toutes les équipes sont présentes à puce
du renfort
on pourrait voir environ 12 personnes on
va installer les deux tirages à berlin
et steria supplémentaires on a un peu
stressé parce qu'on sait que ça va
énormément bouger autour de la place de
la libération joueront les tête
d'affiche on se prépare en conséquence
pour aller plus vite la carte de cette
brasserie sera réduite et le lieu sera
plus surveillés en travailler avec des
agents de sécurité donc l'accès à
l'intérieur est interdit à part si on
met un tampon aux clients pour qu'ils
puissent aller aux toilettes parce que
sinon tout le monde veut rentrer et
sortir comme ils veulent
ça change beaucoup votre la nature notre
clientèle
un événement comme ça c'est sûr qu'on
n'a pas la même clientèle on n'a plus
une clientèle de jeunes ce jour-là que
par rapport à d'habitude on va avoir une
clientèle par exemple autant des ducs
plus posé et plus on va dire plus âgés
les concerts démarrent à 18h coupure de
la musique
à une heure du matin la soirée de
rentrée des serveurs promet d'être
longue